but you know what nobody's coming to
save you and you see this everywhere
where authoritarianism just takes hold
you know everybody's like well we just
need a savior and that's why you get
that charismatic leader that comes in
and destroys the country and you know
maybe that charismatic leader that we
need to save us As Trump but I doubt it
no but he was in power before and he did
nothing for Julian Assange he did
nothing for Edward Edward Snowden he did
nothing for Ross ulbrich he's done
nothing to change the situation that
we're in now he had the opportunity four
years was plenty yeah but there's nobody
else there is nobody else I agree with
you there's nobody else and at this
point it's Trump or nobody but we can't
expect that Trump is going to come save
us we have to understand that it's going
to come from us and it's going to come
from Americans number one understanding
history understanding where this is
going and then doing something about it
because they can't control us if we
don't allow them to you